hey guys this is MIDI with Max 2nd today
we've got the brand-new 2018 13-inch
MacBook Pro for $1,300 and we're gonna
be comparing it to the old 2017 function
keys MacBook Pro so let's go ahead and
start unboxing this guy right here and
we're gonna be comparing everything from
the speakers to the keyboards to
performance and everything like that
alright let's get this bad boy unboxed
here we go we got the silver model oh
nice
there you go oh it's beautiful
just get the box out of the way let's
open this guy up whoop brand new fresh
so it's great about the new 2019 model
is that it's the same exact $1,300 price
and it gets a bunch of awesome new
features added on for example the
keyboard switches have been updated with
the new materials that are gonna be much
more reliable just like the 15-inch
model that came out just a couple of
months ago and we've yet to hear any
issues with that model and if you do
have any issues Apple will fix it
completely for free for the next four
years after your purchase so before I
get everything loaded up and started
let's just quickly test out the keyboard
to see if there's any differences so oh
it's a lot more quiet you can definitely
tell that the old keyboard is really
really clicky and this new one feels a
little bit maybe a little mushy or
definitely more quiet than the other one
and as you guys can see right here the
new 13-inch model finally gets the touch
bar as standard for the same $1,300
price we've got the touch bar right here
and we've got the touch ID sensor right
over here wow this one the old 2017
model gets the function keys and on the
outside there is literally no difference
it's exactly the same no changes at all
same really thin sleek awesome design so
originally we thought that this MacBook
Pro doesn't come with hey Siri but it
actually does I'm here in this setup
right here as you guys can see so that's
pretty awesome
and here we are in the touch ID setup
let's quickly go through that and as you
can see putting in my fingerprint right
here that's really awesome
that you're getting this touch ID with
the touch bar on the $1,300 model comes
standard now and what's great about this
new model is that it now comes with true
tone just like the more expensive
MacBook Pros as you guys can see the
display actually changes the white
balance to match your surroundings like
the room that you're in and when you
turn it off the screen becomes more blue
especially if you're in a tungsten lit
room which is really great to get at the
standard price one thing that's also
different is that the new 13-inch
MacBook Pro also gets a larger battery
but you should still see around the same
battery life because you're getting
quite a bit more performance on this guy
which we'll show you in just a minute
and another thing is that the new one
also gets Bluetooth 5 instead of
Bluetooth 4.2 on this old 2017 MacBook
Pro and that's going to help you with
things like the new air pods - which do
support bluetooth 5 now one thing I'm
curious about is if the speaker's have
been upgraded from the 2017 to the 2019
so let's go ahead and test them out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
right so it's very very hard to tell I
think they might be exactly the same
speakers they both sound amazing much
better than a lot of the Windows laptops
that we've tested before so one thing I
noticed on the spec sheet is that the
new MacBook Pro actually has one more
microphone than the old one so let's go
ahead and do a screen recording or a
movie recording and test out the
microphone and the webcam quality as
well this is an audio quality tests on
the 2017 macbook pro this is an audio
quality tests on the new 2019 macbook
pro now let's get into what you guys
have been waiting for performance and as
you guys know the new 2019 13-inch model
has a quad core processor now compared
to the old dual core on the 2017 and the
graphics hasn't been upgraded as well so
let's go ahead and start with Geekbench
for here we are on the new macbook pro
let's go ahead and run the cpu benchmark
so this is actually really awesome we're
getting a higher single core score even
though the base clock is lower and if
you look at multi-core we're almost
getting double the score as the dual
core 2017 model now that's really
impressive now let's move on to graphics
with the Kika bench floors mettle test
and let's go ahead and run it just like
that so as you guys can see it's
definitely faster than the old MacBook
Pro we're getting thirty five thousand
and metal so that's a really good
improvement and finally let's finish it
off by running Cinebench r15 the classic
for processor performance here we go and
as you guys can see we're getting almost
double the Cinebench r15 score so I'm
really really impressed with this new
13-inch MacBook Pro it's the same exact
price and you're just getting so much
more value you're getting much more
processor performance you're getting the
true tone display you're getting the
touch bar as standard with touch ID and
apples t2 chip so there you have it guys
if you want to see more in depth
performance testing of this new 13-inch
MacBook Pro we're actually going to be
doing a direct comparison against this
MacBook Pro in the $1,800 model very
soon so if you're not already subscribed
make sure to subscribe right now and
we're also going to be getting in the
new 13-inch MacBook Air as well and
comparing that machine to this one to
see which one is the better value so if
you guys are not already subscribed
click that button above and make sure to
tap like and click on one of those two
videos right there to check them out
thanks for watching this has been the
video with max sec and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]